- On this episode,
we talk musical.ly
with musical.ly celebs.
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 198
of The #AskGaryVee show.
We've been completely out of
rhythm with the show, India.
I've been ridiculously busy.
I haven't even snapped all
that much in the last 48 hours.
It's been intense and the other
thing with the show in these
190s it seems every
episode now has guests.
I have two more for
you on an episode
I am super excited about.
Much like I put out a video
yesterday about me talking about
Snapchat in 2014, I have a funny
feeling that this video will be
showing up in my social
media in about 18 to 24 months.
As we get to talk about a
platform that is really caught
my attention over the last 6
to 9 months, six months really,
called musical.ly.
The two lovely ladies that are
here with me, this is actually
a really fun episode unlike what
I could've done early on with
Snapchat and brought people in
that were doing extremely well
on Snapchat, I kind of did what
I normally did over the last
decade with Twitter,
YouTube and Facebook.
I learned, I watched.
This is the first time that I'm
bringing people on the show in
an environment where because of
my busy schedule, because of my
own relationship with music,
I'll get into that in a second,
these two young ladies are
far much further along in their
execution and understanding of
musical.ly than I am which is
something I don't like to
do with myself especially
in a public environment.
So I'm excited because I think
you're going to bring a lot of
value not only to the audience
but to me myself and I like
being selfish little bit today.
So why don't you before
we get into the show,
tell the Vayner Nation
who you guys are?
- My name is Ariel Martin but
I'm also known as BabyAriel.
- My name is Ariana Trehills but
I'm also known as theylovearii
and basically we're really--
- Wait, did you
guys rehearse that?
That was very impressive.
(laughter by all)
That was improv.
- Yeah.
- Makes sense. That's why
you guys are winning.
- So it's a lip-synching app
and you can do any kind of
lip-synching videos you want to
hip-hop to pop to comedy and you
get to show your personality
and be creative with it.
- Real quick on the lip syncing
part, I've been looking at it
enough to know some people
lip-synch but there's obviously
other things people can be
doing, interacting, acting
through the music, or
different things of that nature.
Original music.
Are you both lip-synchers?
- [Both] Yes.
- We do--
- Do you guys know each other?
- [Both] Yes.
- Like really well?
- Since sixth grade.
- You guys live
in the same town?
- Two minutes away.
- A minute away from each other.
- And you both won
on this platform?
- [Both] Yes.
(laughter)
- Before you get into a few
things let's actually
take it all the way back.
Couple of things
how old are you guys?
- [Both] 15.
- Amazing. Next, was I funny?
(girls laughing)
- We're just in sync.
- Got it. Respect.
When did you guys first
become aware of musical.ly?
- Well I started actually I
found it through Instagram.
- Okay.
- This girl posted a video using
it and I asked her what app is
that because it looked fast
motion and cool and so I asked
her what app it was and she told
me musical.ly and then from then
I showed my friends that I
happened to also show her.
- And when did that happen?
- May 18th.
- May 18th? Respect.
May 18th.
- May 18th, that's it.
That's the day I showed her I'm
pretty sure and I was on it--
- May 17th.
- Exactly.
May 17th and three fourths.
Okay, fine, you
discover it in May,--
- Yes.
- When did the app come out?
In the US, do you know?
- [Woman] I think two years
ago is when it started
it's very basic form.
- Got it, right, it pivoted
a little bit along the way.
We'll have a more
in-depth I think India--
- [Woman] I'll send
that to you guys.
- I think, you know what,
I think we waited longer
than we even had to on our kind
of complete guide to Snapchat
I think we might as well
take our first at-bat at
a complete guide to
musical.ly so we'll do that.
It's May, at that point, when
she told you about it that was
the first you've heard about it?
- Yes.
- Nobody else at this point
in your school at 15,
what are you guys? Freshmen?
- [Both] Yes.
- Nobody was talking
about it just yet, right?
- No.
- Well, that was
in eighth grade.
- Eighth grade.
Got it, right, last year.
- At that time, yes.
- What happened over the summer?
Did it completely explode?
- [Both] Yes.
- The summer, that time we were
just on it posting random videos
to our friends--
- Yes
- but during the summer that's
when we started to make more.
- I got featured I think most
positive it was the weekend of
July 4 but you are a month
before kind of in June--
- Yes.
- because I was there when you
got featured as she was like
oh my gosh.
- So a piece of your content
got featured by the app?
- Yeah. Basically like --
- What happened overnight?
How many followers did
you go from to how many?
- I remember that week that
video got featured and I got
2000 to 5000 that week and
just kept going and
I was kind of freaking out.
- Yes.
Now how many
followers you have now?
- Now I have 7.4 million.
(Gary chortles)
- I have 3.7 million. Yeah.
- And so are you are the place
now where when you go where do
you kids go now, the mall
or out and about people
are rolling up on you?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Are you taking
a lot of selfies?
- [Both] Yes.
- And you love that?
- I love it, yeah.
- Me too.
I don't think as many as you
I assume with those
kind of numbers.
And so now what?
Good, through summer it picks up
momentum did you couldn't wait
of the first day of school
because you were curious
about like whatever?
- We were nervous.
- I was scared.
- What if everyone doesn't like
us because we getting so much--
- You're about the haters?
- [Both] Yeah.
- Yeah. India's a hater.
- I'm not a hater.
- [Gary] I'm kidding.
I'm kidding.
(laughter by all)
- It was like our first year in
high school so it was a bunch of
new people and we were scared.
- And what happened?
- It was fine.
- Maybe the first week
one or two were like
oh my gosh,
she goes to our school.
- Okay.
- I remember the first day--
- Fairly good.
- We were worried about if
people we were growing so much
they want to be our friends
now and didn't want
to be our friends before.
DRock has that problem now.
(girls laugh) Everybody wants to
be his friend and he's
struggling with balancing if
they actually want to be
his friend or they just
want to be with DRock.
Now talk with me about I
know were going to focus more
musical.ly but I want to bounce
out for second within social.
Prior to that, what apps were
you using January to May
of last year?
- Instagram, Twitter, Snapchat.
- Yeah.
- And so you become a musical.ly
celebrity, has that crossed over
into your
Instagram and Snapchat?
- Yes.
- Yes. Yes.
- And then I don't know if
you're able to answer this
because it makes sense to me I
had my notoriety on my platforms
but then I can act like my
normal self in other places,
are you in a place right now
since is all so new that it kind
of hard for you not to be
the, are you able to be your own
person in those other apps?
- [Both] Yes.
- Do you understand?
- Snapchat.
- In Snapchat?
- You can take them around.
Sometimes we'll take them around
our day what we do or just
basically be ourselves and
show them who we really are.
Not just behind the camera.
- But notice what you
just said, to them.
That's fan base.
How about to your inner circle,
in your life your 7 to 9 core
friends or acquaintances--
- Yeah.
- What you using? Are you
snapchatting directly to them?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Are using Twitter?
- [Both] Yes.
- To do what?
- To tweet.
(everyone laughs)
- Are you using Twitter...
Prior, let's go back,
prior to May
were you using Twitter
to follow celebrities?
- Yes.
- Some, yeah.
- But Twitter was number three
behind Instagram and
Snapchat for you right?
- [Both] Yes.
- Right. Have you ever
heard of Facebook?
- [Both] Yes. We're on Facebook.
We're not as good on it.
- I get it. I get it.
And have you started
thinking about YouTube?
- Yeah, we do the
weekly YouTube videos.
- Got it.
Now what's happening
what is it right now April?
Freshman year is
starting to wrap up, right?
- Yes.
- So what's happening
with the friends around you?
Where's musical.ly now sitting
with the 15 year-olds and more
importantly, actually do
you have younger siblings?
- I have a little brother.
- How old is he?
- 12.
- And what is he using?
- He uses everything.
Besides YouTube.
- What's his order
in your opinion?
What's his favorite app?
- He loves musical.ly.
- Of course, his
sister's a fucking star.
Oh sorry, can't curse with them.
- It's okay.
(girls laughing)
- Okay he loves musical.ly.
- Next, he's a very
good Snapchatter.
- You respect his skills?
- Yes I didn't know you
could be very skilled.
- Now are his 12 year old
friends also
using those two apps?
- Yes.
- Okay.
And what's
happening in high school?
In high school, freshman class
musical.ly and Snapchat, one and
two, or Instagram
give me the ratings.
This is complete
data collection for me.
- [India] Yes!
- This is a personal episode.
(girls laughing)
- I don't think
musical.ly has passed Snapchat.
- Right. So it's Snapchat.
Where's musical.ly and Instagram
sitting in your opinion?
Your class, your school.
- None of my friends use
Instagram like that
no more at all.
They usually just basically
use Snapchat and Twitter.
They don't use Instagram.
- Snapchat and Twitter?
- Yeah.
Twitter's getting up there.
A lot of people--
- Why is Twitter
getting up there?
- Because you're able to
like I guess they can talk--
- Buy Twitter stock.
(laughter from everyone in room)
- they can talk to
each other on Twitter.
- And you see a lot of funny
videos and it's just so many
funny things happen on Twitter.
I love Twitter
more than Instagram.
- How are you guys,
what is your family?
Let's show a little bit of this.
Your families are out here.
There they are.
(laughter)
What do they think about,
like what does your dad,
what do they think about that?
- My mom at first was like oh
that's really good and the first
time I got noticed she
was like this is real.
You're really getting noticed.
Same as my dad.
My dad has been this was
recently about a month ago we
went to Key West and I got
noticed and he was like
you're so right this is going
somewhere and
now everywhere do
you know her?
Do you know her?
This is my daughter.
- Yeah, of course.
- The first month I started to
really like blowup and we were
all kind of like
what's going on?
Okay get the domain name
for BabyAriel.com,
get a YouTube channel
right now, Ariel.
- Who was saying that?
- My dad.
- Nice work.
- And my mom also.
I remember he was like
the first week he's like
get the domain name.
We're getting the
domain BabyAriel.com.
Me and my mom looked at him
like are you serious, José?
Come on.
(laughter from all)
- José was right.
- José was very right.
We're like thank God
José was a know it all.
- So actually let's
go this route,
what would you like to see,
what do you think musical.ly
is doing well that you like
better than the other platforms?
What I like about it is that
you're not just you don't just
have to do lip-synching,
you don't have to comedy,
you can really make whatever
kind of video that you want.
You can add someone else's
voice and you can lip-synch
to their comedy voice.
You can lip-synch to whatever.
- You can also there's a segment
where you can import videos from
your phone and add music
into its so let's say you
want to put a Snapchat.
Oh add me on Snapchat or then
you visited somewhere really
nice and then you'll put
it in and add some music.
- Even at a picture.
- Do you feel like the music
helps you create content in a
world where other platforms--
- Yes.
- It gives you the
springboard to do that?
- Yes, yeah.
- A lot of people say when they
watch our videos on musical.ly
it's kinda like telling
a story with the lyrics.
- Yeah.
- For instance--
- You're interpreting it your
way not directly with the lyrics
but your version
of what's going on.
- Exactly.
- And you can do expression so
it makes it all look
like a real music video.
- Have you discovered music
that you have never known
about without musical.ly?
- Yes. A lot.
- Yes.
- That has changed the
things you like and
things of that nature?
- Yeah.
I mean I have how
many musical.ly videos?
450-ish and most of them I got
through other people so it's
like cool you're exploring
different styles of music that
I never thought I would listen
to just on a regular basis and
learned a lot of
words to all the songs.
- Everyone's like you know
the words on the radio.
I knew that from
musical.ly, I did that one.
- Sometimes I only know only
15 seconds of a certain song.
- Me too I only know the hook.
Real quick are you guys you
guys, you can't wait for summer
vacation to start--
- [Both] Yes.
- so that you don't have to
spend those extra seven hours in
class now you can produce a lot
more musical.ly content,
yeah, okay, good.
Just wanted to make sure.
What about from a
business standpoint?
Have you guys this is
obviously all new territory.
There's a lot of attention on
you guys, have you guys have you
had brands reach out
or are you thinking about,
how are you thinking about
your business worlds?
- Recently, I just
launched my nail polish line.
- This is the best.
(everyone laughing)
- And Ariel you have lipstick.
- I have a lipstick line.
- We have websites with merch.
We kinda do the same thing.
- Yep.
- She has bracelets.
I have bracelets.
Shirts and hats.
- How's it going? Well?
- Very.
- Yes.
- Very, there we go.
- I was just saying.
- I mean listen, this is a
business show so this is exactly
where we get to talk about it.
That's great guys.
I'm super happy for you guys.
- Thank you.
- Alright I think we
should do a question.
- [India] Yeah,
let's do a question.
- Let's do it.
- [Voiceover] Kasey asks,
"How many times does it take
"you to make a musical.ly?"
- Well Kasey it depends on the
song that we're working on or
the type of musical.ly
that we're working on.
Certain songs may
take us an hour.
- It's kind of like saying
we're perfectionists.
If it doesn't look right--
- Then I'll do it again.
- Are you guys producing a
lot of content together?
Like you'll go over to
each other's house and be like
alright, let's get to work.
- Yeah.
- That's cool 'cause since
we live like a minute
away from each other--
- Like you walk?
- We could, we don't.
- What do you do?
- Drive.
- But you don't drive yet.
- No, no, no.
You ask your parents to
drive one minute?
- We do events and stuff
together so our moms will talk
about something that we're going
to do like a couple weeks out.
- We'll do meet and greets
kind of a month ago right
before Spring Break.
- Who's showing up to
the meet and greets?
What percentage are
girls of your age?
- It ranges from like 6--
- I told you.
- I think the youngest
is like 6 to 12, 13.
- I've seen a lot
of 17 year olds.
- Yeah, 17 year olds.
The oldest is probably 17.
- 17.
This one girl came and she was
12 and her older sister was like
22 and she was like my sister
showed me your and I was like
I really like you also.
- Yeah, my cousin had a friend
and she's worked with this girl
for three months or so and
my cousin saw musical.ly
pop up on her phone.
She's like you have musical.ly?
She was like yeah, I love
those two girls and she was like
Arii's my cousin.
She's like no way.
She's like 26 and
I know Ariel too.
- Yeah, if you're on
American Idol people love.
You think 26 is old, right?
Yeah.
- Yeah, not mean but like--
- That hurts Staphon, right?
It's going to happen
to you too man.
Okay, so what about this,
how many boys
show up to these things?
- Maybe like one
or two or three.
- So it's a dominate,
dominate girl crowd.
- Yes. We definitely have boys.
- And is that good?
- We never really...
They're cute.
They're like 12.
- 12 is like super young
for a 15 year old, right?
- No!
(laughter)
- We never really met
most of our boy supporters.
- There was like a meet and
greet that 5 to 8 came boys.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Which is cool to see.
- Of course.
- They're so
nervous they're like hi.
- You guys are
famous chicks them.
They get nervous.
All right India.
- [Voiceover] Luca asks
"What make musical.ly great?
"What's the future of it?"
- What I like most I think
when I go on it allows me to be
creative because I might want to
do comedy one and be funny that
day or I want to make a
lip-synch and depending upon the
song I want to do if
it's a really sad song--
- Will you made sad content
when you're actually sad?
- Yes.
- Or will you make sad content
when you're like I've been doing
a lot of funny, I've been
doing a lot of this.
- Both.
- Yeah.
- Because your strategic?
- Exactly.
As much I want to think of it
whatever I want to do let us do
it but if I did 10 comedies
the other day
I can't do 10 more comedies.
- How many pieces of
content will you do in a day?
- When it's a good day yeah I'm
ready some musical.lys
I'll do like three or four.
If I'm coming home
tired, I'll do one or two.
- And for you?
- Same.
What do you think you'll
do the first day of summer?
- Probably 10.
- Sometimes I'll be like
okay mom leave alone I'm doing
musical.lys and I'll be in
there for like two hours--
- And that's an
acceptable thing, right?
Mom's like oh crap
she's doing musical.ly.
- Exactly. She can't
take the phone away.
- She walks and she's like--
- Mom.
- (whispers) Oh I'm
sorry, I'm sorry.
If I get in trouble I'm like
haha you can't take my phone
away because I can stop posting
musical.lys because they'll be
like where's Arii
or where's Ariel?
- What about the comments?
Obviously comments, especially
at the young ages they you're at,
right, how down do you get
when the comments are mean or
how do you deal with positive
versus negative comments?
- At the beginning, when I
first started there was a lot of
comments and it was like mean.
I have a really high esteem
so I was like I don't care.
I don't even look at
my comments at all.
I don't look at none of them.
- Right because you don't
want to get down on
the stuff that's negative.
- Yeah.
- I actually started an
anti-bullying movement because
at first I got a lot of comments
in the same thing
just for stupid things.
Oh you're ugly, oh what
are you doing? Duh, duh, duh.
And instead of pushing to the
side because that's what most
people I saw do
they just ignore it.
I tweeted about and I was like
this isn't right because if I'm
getting it then who
knows there might be
another little girl that gets it.
- Of course. And for
many people watching
you're a little girl so
that makes sense.
Real quick have you thought
about engaging the comments?
Do you say thanks
when people
are giving you love and
things like that nature?
- On Instagram it's really hard
to see because I have so much.
I have 1.1 million, she has 1.9
it's hard to see, but Twitter is
mainly where I notice a lot of
people and I'll favorite all the
tweets when I tweet.
- Got it.
- On Intagram, it's hard like
she said it's hard to do one by
one but there's days where I'll
post a picture of me hugging a
supporter and saying
thank you to everybody.
- And how do you think in
community in musical.ly?
- Huh?
- How do you think about
the community in musical.ly?
- I think it's positive, there's
just some kids that are cruel
and they'll just go on to our
pages, comment rude things.
- Have you thought of engaging
with them are incorporating them
into your content?
- Yeah. I actually
thank you of that.
I talked about that with
my family the other day.
I wanted to start doing
once a week of maybe
a duet competition.
- And how you guys
think about collaborations?
Obviously I assume you guys
collaborate with each other
that was easy have you
done a lot of collabos?
- Yes. Not a lot I've done
on with three or four.
- Do you get asked by a lot of
people who are trying to build
up their musical.lys
to do a collaboration?
- Not really.
If I collabed with someone
it'll probably be like my cousin
because she's also
musical.ly and she loves it.
Were going to actually an
event and a week or so like 10
days called Playlist Live and
all of our friends that we're in
a group chat with are going to
be there so they all want to
collab and we're very excited.
- DRock. Let's get over
there and collab.
Okay, India.
- [Voiceover] Paul asks, "Will
Snapchat ever allow us to
"sort our friends into groups?
If not, why?"
- I really hope they add a
friends list or change that
aspect up a little bit.
- Yeah because sometimes I want
to send it to a person and then
I accidentally click a wrong
name and said it's the wrong
person and I'm like oh sorry.
Maybe should they should be able
to let you choose friend groups.
Let's say you, let's be real, I
want to send it to Ariel,
this so and so maybe
I should have a friend list,
this group, I want to
send to this group.
- My point of view on it
India and crew is I think what's
Snapchat and musical.ly have
done really well as the next
generation platforms that
have attention is they've not
followed the historic patterns
of the other platforms which I
think has brought a lot of
relevance to this demo so I
think the be very calculated.
I think Evan's clearly shown
over the last three years that
he has no interest in paying
attention to what everybody else
wants him to do with the product
and I think he'll be pretty
calculated with
where he goes with it.
I think even if the demo is pent
up and asking for they're not
going to be so quick
to add that feature.
I think they clearly want to be
the number one at messaging app
in the world hence why they put
so much into this latest update.
Speaking of which,
how did you like the latest
update in Snapchat?
- I don't like that --
- Too many things?
- No, I like the filters and
everything I just like the story
part when you're done watching
someone's story it automatically
goes to the next one.
I don't like that.
- It's too much effort for you
to just go up and get out of it?
- Well sometimes
it just come quick.
- Your finger is bothered.
Maybe your nail polish is too
wet and you don't want to do it.
- Sometimes it's like if you
get onto and I just click it out
it's still there showing that
it's a recent update and
that bothers me.
I like to clear it out.
- Understood. And for you?
What about the chat,
one-on-one chat function?
Apologize, I'll come right back.
DRock you know I did
that for everybody--
- [DRock] Yep.
- to leave a comment.
My people love to leave comments
that I interrupt and so I do it
on purpose because
I love the hate.
So what's your point of
view on the chat aspect?
- The chat aspect I think it's
cool I haven't really gotten a
chance to--
- Really delve into it?
- Yeah.
- Just making too
many musical.ly's.
- Exactly.
- One last thing I definitely
want to know one more time in
the collective high school
you're in where if you had to
have one net score freshmen
to seniors the ranks just your
opinions the number one
app is Snapchat right now?
- No, Twitter. For my
school it's Twitter.
- Really?
- Yes.
Twitter is--
- Twitter's the number one, the
number one across all users of
all four grades the amount
of people that are
on it and using it?
- Twitter.
- Twitter because everyone is
like did you see Twiter Video?
- This is unbelievable. Wow.
- What's your Twitter?
- Follow me on Twitter.
- Interesting.
- And next is
probably Snapchat.
- Yeah and then?
Not a lot of people really like,
they don't like musical.ly.
They think it's cool
that we do it but
they don't really go on it.
They made some here
and there and they're
like yeah and they're like--
- Are they consuming?
Because I understand
making versus consuming
is a whole other thing.
I do think the barrier of
making a very
good musical.ly is harder.
I do think one thing the
Snapchat has going for it
is you can be like psssh.
You know, this clearly a
creative level on musical.ly
similar to YouTube, similar to
other platforms, similar,
by the way, to early Instagram
and this is actually
where musical.ly goes.
I think musical.ly now has a
threshold of creative but I'm
very curious does it go the
route of YouTube and continues
to be important and always
important or does it go the
route of Instagram did because
early Instagram you had to have,
it was really photography sites.
- Yeah.
- That was the early crew
and then mainstreamed out.
Watching this mainstream out
from afar for me in your demo
and younger especially as you
start seeing these 7, 8, 9, 10,
11, 12-year-olds it will be
interesting to see if people are
willing to not make perfect are
you to be a place in 24 months
where you'll be thinking
differently of the level of a
musical.ly that you need to make
versus the way thinking
about it today?
- That's a hard question.
- [India] Do you want to
show how you make one?
- Yeah.
- Just a quick one minute demo
of how you make one
because it's pretty cool.
- Okay.
- Okay. Any song in particular?
- [India] No, your favorite.
You pick.
- [Woman] What was the song
you guys did this morning?
It was good.
- Blessings?
- [Woman] Can you
do that together?
- Oh, "Me, Myself and I".
- We do that one?
- Basically you
choose your song--
- Why don't you
get up and we'll...
- Want to explain it?
Go back so you can
see the music part.
So there's different settings
epic, slow, normal,
fast and lapse.
Epic is fast, right?
- Epic, here I'll show you.
Epic is (music play
3x normal speed).
- Slow is going to be fast.
Normal is normal and then fast
is what we use and
it a slow motion.
(music playing at half speed)
And then it just combines
it to be fast.
It looks cool and then there's a
timer that they just added and I
now you can switch the camera
and also you can slide to where
you want to play it.
- And they provide you with 30
seconds if it's on because they
have songs on there but you also
get from your own library and
you can choose
from the whole song.
- And have you been happy with
the speed in which the feature
updates have been
coming through?
- Yes.
- Yes, very happy.
- Alright, good.
- So you want us to
make one? Together?
- [India] Yeah, that'd be fun.
- Together. Okay, ready?
- [Phone, Music Half Speed]
♫ Oh, it's just me, myself and I ♫
♫ Solo ride until I die
Cause I got me for life ♫
♫ Got me for life,
Oh I don't need a hand to hold ♫
♫ Even when the night is cold ♫
♫ I got that fire in my soul ♫
- Love it. India,
let's clap that up.
(applause)
- And then it comes out fast.
- [Phone, Music Full Speed]
♫ Solo ride until I die
Cause I got me for life ♫
♫ Got me for life,
Oh I don't need a hand to hold ♫
♫ Even when the night is cold ♫
♫ I got that fire in my soul ♫
- Good for you guys.
I'm going to wrap this up.
When I have guests on they get
to ask a question of the day
of the audience.
So these people are
very, very old
like 25 to 40 who are watching.
(Ariel laughs)
And so what question would
you like to ask that demo
in the context of where your
world's at right now?
You each can ask one question.
- Arii.
(nervous laughter)
- Maybe your curious of what
that business world thinks or
what that demo thinks.
What's your gut?
- This is hard.
- I have a lot of questions
but I don't know where to go.
- You can go anywhere with it.
You can play some music.
- Huh?
- Just kidding. Go ahead.
- Okay.
(Ariel singing)
- Does it have to be a question?
- No.
You can do whatever
the hell you want.
You want a statement of the day?
You like statements,
you've got things to say.
- This is a statement of the day.
- I think musical.ly is a
well-rounded app and it's for
all ages and I think that older
age group should be able to do
it to and express how they want
to use songs from their past
when they were a
child and bring it back.
- The old days.
- Yeah, bring it
back to the new days.
Show this is what I
used to listen to.
- Have you noticed some of the
older have you seen the older
demo starting the last
couple weeks to months?
- There's some.
- Uh-huh.
- There are some people that are
older and they start using which
I like it because I like
old-school music personally.
- And what you
consider old-school?
Early 2000's? My mom
is like 37 I think.
She was born in the 80s, 90s and
so I listened to 90s,
DMX, Biggie and all that.
- Old, old stuff.
- I've done musical.ly's to a
lot of old-school songs because
she loves what I do them.
- Yep.
I think it would be great for
older people to try it and maybe
it'll bring back
their childhood memories.
- We love memories.
Thank you.
You got a question
or a statement.
- So based on that, then will
you guys try musical.ly and try
it out and how do you
guys think it will be?
how do you like
it and everything?
- I love it.
Ladies, thank you
so much for coming.
- Thank you for having us.
- So much fun you guys.
I wish you nothing the best.
Let's do this.
These ladies came all the way
out here to have this amazing
show gave us a lot of
insight, buy Twitter stock.
One of the things about the
show is you know I want actions.
I want to help a lot of you.
I do see this as a platform that
is going to continue to age up
and more importantly
musical.ly's big enough right
now that you have
to take the bet.
Will musical.ly become
Snapchat and Instagram?
My early intuitions are
I think it's got a real shot.
Could it become a
Yik Yak or SocialCam?
Sure. That's part of the game
but it's already at a scale
and a size right now that
for every one of you
49-year-old Don
construction worker.
Children not to parents all
of you need to go figure out,
especially I alluded to this
music much like photography is
not something that
comes very naturally to me.
I already know I have
put out two musical.lys,
I haven't done anything.
I haven't lip-sync, I haven't
done anything yet but I'm
desperately thinking, I've been
thinking of I'm just going to
make Rick Ross hustling
music over my day-to-day
because that's what I'm doing.
I think we all have to challenge
ourself to figure our creative
outlet in a platform that's
growing especially for
a lot of you that have
brands that want to sell
to 13 to 25 this is a
demo that's going to live
in this platform as we
head into and the reason
why I brought up summer quite
a bit if you look at historic
nature of social networks
enormous growth happens in that
summer when they're all home and
they can produce more and they
can talk more and not tied up.
I think we're just on the verge
of a very important three-month
period for this platform and
I would take that
very, very seriously.
Ladies, thank you again.
- [Both] Thank you.
- Good luck with your shirts
and your line and your lipstick
lines and your
nail polish lines.
India, you like that.
That was impressive, right?
- [India] That was
really impressive.
- You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(upbeat hip hop music)